dieses foto ist wirklich mehr als
eindrucksvoll die rede ist von der nasa
aufnahme eines fast perfekt rechteckigen
eisbergs fotografiert wurde das
mysteriöse objekt im antarktischen
weddellmeer während eines forschungsflug
seitdem rätselt das ganze netz was
dahinter steckt und diese eisberg ist
nicht die einzige ungewöhnliche
entdeckung der nasa in der jüngsten zeit
die so perfekt geometrisch ist wie diese
form zustande kommt und wer wohl dafür
verantwortlich ist klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
unglaubliches science videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er keins
herzlich willkommen diese eisbergs sieht
viel zu symmetrisch aus um wahr zu sein
oder wurde er etwa künstlich
zugeschnitten oder aber die aufnahme im
nachhinein einfach mit photoshop
bearbeitet
fest steht aber der eisberg sie zwar
unnatürlich aus ist aber echt und zwar
tatsächlich in dieser gigantische form
eines müsliriegel entdeckt wurde der
außergewöhnliche eisberg bei dem nasa
forschungsprojekt namens operation eis
bridge hierbei sollen die veränderungen
der eisverhältnisse in den polarregionen
dokumentiert werden eine mitarbeiterin
der nasa beschreibt den mysteriösen
eisberg im mittelmeer vor der antarktis
als ungewöhnliches exemplar das fast wie
ein perfekter quader aussieht zu
erkennen sind die scharfen winkel und
eine flache oberfläche bislang gingen
die forschungsteams deswegen davon aus
dass der eisberg gerade frisch von der
front des lassen c schelfeises an der
ostküste der antarktischen küste
abgebrochen sein muss doch jetzt gibt es
neue erkenntnisse dazu
der eckige tafel eisberg ist
offensichtlich schon im november 2017
abgebrochen
entstanden ist er wohl kurz nach dem
abbruch des gigantischen a 68 eisbergs
vom lassen c schelfeis seine vorläufer
sind auf satellitenbildern zu erkennen
die zu diesem zeitpunkt aufgenommen
worden sind zwei frische kräfte eisberge
neben einem gebogenen als stück eben
auch ein relativ rechteckige eisberg
dieser art wohl seitdem schon eine sehr
lange reise hinter sich seit ende 2017
trieb er langsam nach norden und stieß
immer wieder mit eisstücken zusammen
unter anderem gelangen er auch durch
eine richtige gefahrenzone hindurch
nämlich eine
engstelle mit felsigen vorsprung die von
experten und expertinnen auch als
nussknacker bezeichnet wird denn
eisberge die hierhin durchtreiben
bleiben meistens nicht unbeschadet so
auch der vorläufer des mysteriösen
rechteck eisbergs der zerbricht zu
entstehen einige geometrische formen
bruchstücke darunter eben auch unser
rechteck eisberg fachleute bezeichnen
solche objekte als sogenannte tafel
eisberge solche langen und flachen
eisberge bilden sie indem sie sich eben
von den schelfeis rändern abspalten
laut der nasa ist die entstehung solcher
tafeln eisberge mit einem fingernagel zu
vergleichen der zu lange wächst und
letztendlich dann abbricht solche tafel
eisberge sind übrigens eher typisch für
die antarktis die eisberge die wir
beispielsweise vom film titanic im kopf
haben laufen nach oben spitz zu uns sind
dagegen charakteristisch für die akten
die bildung von tafel eisbergen ist
tatsächlich ein natürliches phänomen
doch wir berichten hier bei klicks und
science fiction immer wieder darüber
laut studien schmilzt das eis in der
antarktis immer schneller und das rapide
abbrechen großer flächen vom schelfeis
wird wohl vom klimawandel begünstigt das
krasse an dem jetzt entdeckten exemplar
die nasa aufnahme zeigt wohl nur etwa
zehn prozent des eisberges etwa 900
meter breit und 1500 meter lang der rest
befindet sich unter dem meeresspiegel
und ist dort wohl wahrscheinlich längst
nicht mehr so recht eckig und kantig
mittlerweile hat sich der eisberg weiter
nach norden ins offene wasser bewegt und
wird wohl irgendwann tauen und ich hatte
es schon kurz erwähnt diese
außergewöhnliche eisberg ist nicht die
einzige kuriose entdeckung der jüngsten
zeit mitte oktober hatte ein nasa
forschungsteam eine weitere mysteriöse
geometrische form entdeckt und auch
fotografiert ein angesagtes dreieck
nämlich dass an ein stück pizza erinnert
den link zum pizza eisberg den findet
ihr in der video beschreibung wenn er
garantiert kein video bei klicks und
verpassen wollt dann abonniert klicks um
auf englisch ja einfach draufklicken
denn da gibt es auch videopremieren wie
zb erst letzte woche das interview mit
harvard professor edward zum thema ist
humor moore eine alien
und da drunter geht's weiter mit
competition vor allen masc flying cranes
von china
wir sehen uns auf dem englischen kann
dann hoffentlich von pixum stay tuned
ein ziel zu